Herkese selamlar sevgiler hepiniz hoş
geldiniz
sevgiyle geldiniz sevgiyle gidin Bir
ömür boyu hep mutlu kalın Ben Hasan
Yıldız
herkes gibi herkesin
başarı hikayesi var Ben hayatım boyunca
şuna inanan birisiyim
başarısız insan yok Herkes takdire değer
diyorum kısaca kendimden biraz
bahsedeyim
sona doğru da buradan ayrıldıktan sonra
şuna inanıyorum binlerce gencede
söyledim yıllar sonra karşılaştığımda
gençlerle şunu gördüm Hasan abi
söylediğin sözler kulaklarımızda
çınlıyor Bu o kadar değerli ki
Evet
şimdi
Annem tabii biz alt kardeşiz üç kız üç
erkek babamı 93'te kaybettim Annem
hayatta
burada bu yakışıklı küçük Afacan benim
annemin kucağında aynı o ruhla yaşıyorum
1974 doğumluyum ama ruhum değişmedi
çocukluğunuzu kaybederseniz her şeyinizi
kaybedersiniz Bunu hiçbir zaman
unutmayın o ruhu kaybetmeyin
ablam dünya tatlısıdır anne en köşede
diğer küçük ablam çocukluk arkadaşım ve
abim
aramızda benim canım her şeyim Yol
Arkadaşım mesai arkadaşım diğer Kardeşim
burada birazdan takdim edeceğim Ondan
şimdi
Değerli arkadaşlarım
ekranda görmüş olduğunuz
bir daktilo
diyeceksiniz ki
Hocam neden daktilo ekranda benim ilk
meslek hayatıma başladığım
1992'de 18 yaşıma girdiğimde ilk işimi
kurduğum
çıraklık olarak çalışarak biriktirdiğim
haftalıklarla
o zaman gecekonduda oturuyorduk Biz
aslında Erzurumluyuz Ankara Yenimahalle
Demetevler'de büyüdüm ben
tabii
Ben hep şunu söylüyorum Her yerde
varlıkta da Mutluluk yoklukta da
mutluluk varsa her zaman başı ve
mutluluk var O dönemlerde de
gözlerimizin içi gülüyordu Çünkü öyle
bir anne babanın oğluydu ki çocuklarıydı
ki biz bir şeye dayalı mutluluğa inanan
insanlar değildik mutluluk insan içinde
olmalıydı
Çocukluğumda tamirciliği ile geçti
aldığın haftalıkları biriktirerek
ev adresiyle Tabii ki işleri açacak
Paramız yoktu o dönemde ev adresine
vergiye mükellef oldum
o dönemlerde 18 yaşındaydım 1992'de
Tabii teknoloji yok arkadaşlar şimdi
istediğimiz zaman her şeye
ulaşabiliyoruz
ama o zaman hiçbir şeye ulaşamıyorsunuz
özgüveniniz yüksekse Aslında her şey
size ulaşıyor Benim de özgüvenim
maşallahın var Yani çok yüksek Her zaman
da yüksek hayallerimde hiçbir zaman
bitmedi bitmeyecek
Sizlerin de hayalleri hiçbir zaman
Bitmesin 18 yaşında İnter teknik diye
bir daktila tamirciliği kurdum
arkadaşlar ev adresler yerken mükellef
oldum ama bir eksiğim vardı tam Usta
olamamıştım bana bir ortak lazımdı
kalfan vardı Çorumlu çok sevdiğim Rüştü
abi
O da askerden gelmişti ona ortaklık
teklif ettim
dedim ki benimle ortak olur musun şöyle
bir baktı bana
ev adresini vergiye mükellef olmuşuz
daktilo tamirciliği bir tonla tornavida
pense ve havyadan oluşan bir şey teknik
ekipman gerekiyor
şöyle bir güldü ya Hasan dedi sen ne
diyorsun dedi ya dedi Ben tekrar
ayrıldım yere işe gireceğim ve
evleneceğim yuvamı kuracağım
Düzenli bir gelirim olacak dedi
sen dedim bana takıl çok güzel düğün de
yaparsın çok iyi bir geleceğin de olur
çok güzel para kazanırız dedim çünkü o
dönemde tekneden oje yok bilgisayar yok
her yerde daktilo var arkadaşlar Aslında
dünyanın her yerindeki arşivler İşte bu
daktilolarla yazıldı yeni nesil belki
Tam kavramayabilir burada büyüklerimiz
var
ve tarihler yazıldı odakçılarıyla
işimizi kurduk ki Haydi senle bir Ankara
dışına çıkalım Yozgat'a gittik
dedim o kadar inanmışım ki o kadar
inandırmış ki ben gittiğimde orada deli
gibi para kazanacağım böyle ceplerim
dolu bir şekilde eve geleceğim
sadece yol paramız var hiç unutmuyorum
o dönemlerde sigara serbestti
otobüslerde Her Şey serbestti ben de
yorgunluk vardı
gözlerimi açtığımda şurada bir ayak izi
var bir koku hissettim
hiç unutmuyorum Döndüm baktım
75 yaşlarında bir amca
Muhtemelen rahatsız hasta hiç ses
çıkartmadım uyumaya devam ettim
Çünkü büyükler Bizim nefesimiz her
şeyimiz
hep o ruhla Biz büyüdük
arkadaşlar Yozgat'a gittik öyle bir
inandırmışım ki kendimi kurumları
geziyoruz hiç iş yapamadık akşam saat 5
oldu
dönüş Paramız da yok
Rüştü abi ile öyle bir konuşarak
götürdüm ki ben onu o dedi ki Tamam İyi
para kazanırız yuvamızı kurarız
geleceğimiz garanti altına alırız şunu
söyledi bana Allah uzun ömür versin
sürekli Görüştüğüm bir abim Ya Hasan
dedi Ne yaptın dedi ya ben dedi dönmek
istiyorum dedi sen dönme dedim sabırlı
ol Bizim Anadolu insanı o kadar
misafirperver ki Arkadaşlar bir
misafirhaneye gittik ve bizi misafir
ettiler o gün 15 dakikada Ben Rüştü
abiyi ikna ettim burada size bir mesaj
verebilirim
inandığınız süre içerisinde inandığınız
size ve karşınızdaki insana zarar
vermediğinize inandığınız takdirde
ikna edemeyeceğiniz hiçbir şey yok
ulaşamayacağınız hiçbir şey yok inanmak
Zaten başarmanın yarısı arkadaşlar
dünyada zaten 50 yılda bir nesillere el
değiştiriyor her şeye sahip
olabilirsiniz ama geride eser bırakmak
çok daha değerli o gün kaldı
Zor ikna ettim ama ettim ertesi günü çok
ciddi bir para kazandık
sonra bana dedi ki canım kardeşim
Aslında Ya biliyor musun Hayat Siz
verdikçe herkes canınız
burada benim hikayem başlıyor daktilo
tamirciliği ile devam ettik arkadaşlar
sonrasında şunu gördüm teknoloji
ilerlemeye başladı Bir müddet sonra ben
Üniversitede
bir 3 yıl
kantin işletmeciliği yaptım çok
sevdiğimiz birisi vesile oldu
hayatın boyunca Size de tavsiye ederim
kamuda ve özel sektörde hangi işi
yaparsanız yapın işin küçüğü büyüğü yok
İşin hakkını verdiğimiz süre içerisinde
başarılı ve mutlu olursunuz
samimiyetle
Işıl
bana dediler ki ya sen kantincilik
zordur kardeşim nasıl yapacaksın dediler
Bu benim işim dedim
Niye benim işim dedim Aslında
arkadaşlar Kamuda özel sektörde hangi
işi yaparsanız yapın sadece işin içeriği
değişiyor yönetim şekli çok önemli İyi
yönetemediğiniz hiç bir işi zaten
yapamazsınız içerik değişiyor
güçlü iletişim gerekiyor dedim ki ben bu
işi yaparım ya bu benim işim dedim
ya işte gençler zordur
Siz gençlerin dünyasına bir girin
gençlerin dünyasına girdikten sonra ne
fırtınalar kopuyor Onlar sizin elinizi
bir tutar bir tutar asla bırakmaz
3 yıl boyunca arkadaşlar
bana şunu söyledi diğer işletmeci
arkadaşlar öğrenci ne verirsen gider
fazla kasma kardeşim kendine
şaşırdım ne demek ya öğrenciye ne
verirsen gider diye
Ben hep yabancı müzik Türkçe slow
çalıyordum çok arabeske girmiyordum
sebebi de şu
öğrenci kardeşim ev kirası derdi
olabilir yurtta problemi derdi olabilir
Derslerle ilgili sıkıntı olabilir
sevgili problemi olabilir de olabilir
maddi sıkıntılar olabilir maksimum
düzeyde öğrencilere pozitif anlamda
anlamda enerji yüklüyordum sürekli ve 3
yıl boyunca
bir simidi dahi arkadaşlar peçetesiz
öğrenciye vermedim 3 yıl boyunca 6 ayda
bir tost tabaklarını değiştiren
bardaklarını değiştiren tuzluklarını
değiştiren çay kaşıklarını değiştiren
çarşıya gidip kendi elleriyle kaşarını
köftesini A'dan Z'ye her şeyini Ben
kendimle yaşantım boyunca ne yaparsam
yapayım hep yer değiştiren bir
kardeşinizim
ne dilersen elinle döner gelir seninle
yıllar sonra 3 yıllık bir serüvenim oldu
orada da şunu yaptım 3 yıl önce ilk
başladığımda yanıma giren çay ocağında
çıraklık yapan kardeşime 3 yıl sonunda
Vefa çok önemli benim hayat felsefemde
kendi akrabam dahi olsa benim kendi
güçlü aynı Buradaki gibi arkadaşlar
kırmızı çizginin dışına çıkamıyorsunuz
güçlü Kırmızı çizgileriniz olacak
yanımda çalışan arkadaşlarıma devrettim
yıllar sonra o üniversitede yarışma
programı çektim TRT'ye iki tane ayrı
program çekmiştim
o üniversiteye gitmem gerekiyordu onu
orada yaşamam gerekiyordu sonrasında
oyun Üniversitede 4 veya 5 sefer
konferans verdim
devrettiğim çocukları yanıma çağırdım
konferansta 10 yıl sonra
ya dedim ki çok şey öğretmişim ama bir
şeyi atlamışız arkadaşlar herhalde dedim
10 yıldır aynı tabakları kullanıyorlardı
Siz işinizi kaliteli yaptığınız süre
içerisinde korkmayın başarılı olursunuz
mutlaka kazanırsınız bizde hayat
felsefesi bu
kantin işletmeciliği sonrasında ama o
binlerce üniversiteli gençlerin hep Göz
Göze Geldim ikinci öğretim de vardı
Onların abisi babası kardeşi her şeyi
idi
Çünkü gençler bizim geleceğimiz bakın
Burada şu an bizleri izleyen milyonlarca
insan var ve izleyeceklerde herkese
sesleniyorum
öyle iş ahlakınız olsun ki sizden sonra
ki nesiller de ülkemizi Dünyanın her
yerinde güçlü şekilde temsil etsin
sadece ben ruhuyla asla yaşamayız Biz
ruhunuzu güçlendirin çünkü hiçbir şey
kimseye kalmıyor
sonrasında benim dünya tatlısı bir
kardeşim var Eyüp Yıldız
O da 30 yıldır Organizasyon ve etkinlik
sektöründe çıraklıktan yetişme Biz Tabii
çocukluğumuzda ayakkabı boyacılığı da
yaptık simitte sattık Ben simit satarken
bile Gözlerim gülüyordu bana diyorlardı
hiç derdin yok mu ya kardeşim dünyada
bana bir tane Dertsiz insan gösterin bir
tane problemi olmayan insan gösterin
inanın son nefesinize kadar
dertler bitmez problemler bitmez
sıkıntılar bitmez adı değişir şekli
değişir zamanı değişir içeriği değişir
Siz öldükten sonra bir o sıkıntılar
geride kalır asla bitmez takılı
kalırsanız kalırsınız kaldığınız yerde O
yüzden çok fazla düşünmeyeceksiniz
yaşamınız boyunca sosyal hayatınızda ve
İş hayatınızda elinizden geldiğince
pozitif olun
ki önce kendinize
ailenize yaşam alanınıza akrabalık
ilişkilerinize
ülkemize pozitif enerjinizi ne kadar
verirseniz Hem siz mutlu olursunuz Hem
herkes mutlu ve başarılı olur Ben ruhunu
Hayatınızdan çıkarın arkadaşlar
sonrasında Eyüp Bey ile Ben aslında
küçük bir şeyim de vardı Böyle bir
oyunculuk
İstanbul'a gitmiştim
Osman sınavın yanına Bu Kurtlar Vadisi
başlamadan bir hayalim oyunun falan
diyordum Neyse bir saatlik bir çekim
yaptılar Ankara'ya geldiğimde Eyüp dedi
ki bana
abi dedi zamanı geldiğinde hayallerini
gerçekleştirirsin gel Biz birlikte bir
şirket bulalım dedi Senin iş hayatı
deneyimin girişimciliğin benim
sektördeki tecrübem ve çevremi
birleştirelim
ileride yapmak istediğin her şeyi
yapabilirsin dedi
Tamam dedim Çünkü biz de bizim ailede
rahmetli babam ve annem bize şunu
aşıladı oğlum
nefsimize her zaman temiz tutun hiçbir
zaman sadece kardeşler arasında değil
arkadaşlık ilişkilerinizde ve sosyal
hayatınızda da sen Ben değil biz ruhunu
ve değerlerinize sahip çıkın o zaman her
zaman kazanır ve mutlu olursunuz dedi
Biz de Eyüp Kardeşimle birlikte çok
büyük bir organizasyonu etkinlik firması
kurduk iki kardeş sıfırdan 2003'te
arkadaşlar
ne yaptık daktilo tamirci ile
başladığımız teknolojinin olmadığı
dönemde şimdi
2022'de kurmuş olduğumuz organizasyonu
etkinlik firması şu an dünyada sayılı
firmaların arasındayız Türkiye'de değil
arkadaşlar dünyada sayılı firmaların
arasında yüzlerce konserler festivaller
seçim çalışmaları ulusal ve uluslararası
birçok kongreler ne yaptık biz dedik ki
bunlar olmaz Bir tane dedik ki bizim bir
şey yapmamız lazım Eyüp Bey dedi ki
Benim bir hayalim var abi dedi
onu gerçekleştirmemiz lazım dedi çünkü
30 yıllık bir deneyim var öyle bir şey
yaptık ki Allah nasip ederse yakın bir
zamanda Dünyanın her yerinde Fikri
projesi hep yıldıza ait
15 dakika daha hazır 15 dakikada hayal
gibi 15 dakikada bir dattir
arkadaşlar
sesi ışığı sahnesi Hulisi tuvaleti bütün
dünyadaki en son teknolojiyi kullandık
15 dakikada ister konser yapın ister
Festival yapın ister miting yapın açık
hava sinema etkinlikleri yapın Eyüp
beyin hayalinde gerçekleştirdik dedik ki
Biz Türküz genciyiz asla yaşlanmayacağız
çok çalışacağız çalışacağız çalışacağız
dedik ve hayalimizde gerçekleştirdik zor
mu değil
inanmak başarmanın yarısı ama hep
söylüyorum yüzlerce üniversite gezdim
binlerce gençlerle iç içe oldum sağ
olsun o sponsorum da hep yıldızdır ücret
almıyoruz biz konferanslardan gönüllülük
esaslı Çünkü paylaştıkça
zenginleşirsiniz hiç unutmayın Ben ruhu
yok diyoruz ya biz ruhuyla koşarsak her
zaman başarılı mutlu oluruz
bitti mi bitmedi
hepimizin işi bitmedi Yolumuz uzun
Bedeni ne bizden sonraki bir nesil
geliyor gençler geliyor gençleri Biz Her
anlamda başarı ve mutlu
başarılı nasıl olunur mutlu nasıl olunur
biz değerlerimize nasıl sahip çıkarız
ruhuyla hepimizin koşması lazım Çünkü
biz Bugün varız yarın yokuz sağlam
nesiller yetiştirmek istiyorsak herkese
büyük sorumluluklar düşüyor o ruhla
yaşıyoruz ve yaşayacağız buradan çok az
bir zamanımız kaldı
tedx organizasyonunu yapan tüm
yöneticilerine ben çok teşekkür ediyorum
En çok da buradaki olan herkese teşekkür
ediyorum sadece kendinizi alkışlayın 30
saniye bırakmayın kendinizi sevin
daha güçlü bu kadar mı seviyorsunuz
daha güçlü herkes değerli her yerde
söylüyorum ve Bütün öğrencileri Diyorum
ki çok değerlisin ama o kadar değerlisin
ki değerinin farkına varmıyorsun niye
vermiyorsun ya kardeşim Herkes o kadar
kıymetli ve değerli ki ben diyorum ki
genelde hep böyle karşımızdaki insanı
iyi tanırız yaşamımız boyunca hiç
kendimizi tanımayız önce kendimizi iyi
tanıyalım
Ben kimim
Kendimizi çok iyi tanırsak arkadaşlar
çok daha başarılı ve mutlu oluruz hep
karşımızdaki insanları tanımaya
çalışıyoruz bırakın önce kendinizde bir
yüzleşin ya gerçekten Ben nasıl bir
insanım daha iyi nasıl bir insan
olabilirim Şu an dünyanın neye ihtiyacı
var biliyor musunuz para makam gelip
geçici net söylüyorum hiç kimse hiçbir
şeyini götürmedi Çünkü 5 yılda 10 yılda
15 Yılda 20 yılda 25 yılda para ve makam
el değiştiriyor Dün ben ayakkabıacılığı
yapıyordum ama ben ayakkabı boyacılığı
yaptığım dönemdeki ruhumu kaybetmedim
ruhunuzu kaybetmeyin geçmişe geleceğe
bakın ama geçmişe de eser bırakan
insanlar olalım Çünkü dünya o kadar
hızlı değişiyor ki size gerçekten
yalvarıyorum bir kardeşiniz olarak
gençliğimizin elini tutalım onları
dinleyelim onlarla birlikte koşalım
tecrübelerimizi birikimlerimizi
insanlarla paylaşalım sakın küçümsemeyin
il il geziyorum ben bakın Türkiye'nin
her yerini diyorum ki kardeşim valimiz
belediye başkanlarımız muhtarlarımız
sorumluluğu olan koltuğu olan iş
adamlarımız yerinizde oturmayın
kapılarınızı kapatmayın sonuna kadar
açın gençlere Yüreğinizi açın ellerini
tutun ki daha güçlü ve büyük Türkiye
olalım Hepinizi o kadar çok seviyorum ki
beni dinlediğiniz için çok teşekkür
ediyorum ömrünüzün sonuna kadar hep
mutlu olun Mutlu kalın yaşadığınız süre
içerisinde
sevdiklerinize çok sarılır
sevdiklerinizle kaybettikten sonra
mezarın başında ağlamak fayda etmiyor
yaşarken aldığı nefes süre içerisinde
çok sarılın çok Sevin ellerinde
bırakmayın arkadaşlar kaybettikten sonra
Oo işte geçiyor hepimizde şöyle bir
özellik var ya iş işten geçiyor derken
inanın çok önemli Çok şey konuşabilirim
ama dar bir zamanımız var size bir
tavsiyeye hayatınızda diyorum ama
sevdiklerinize çok sarılın çok çalışın
Çok çaba sarf edin gençlerin elini tutun
diye hayatınızdan keşkeleri yok edelim
mazeretleri yok edin tembelliği yok edin
ertelemeleri yok edin yok ederseniz
kaybetmezsiniz kazanırsınız Sevgiyle
kalın Allah'a emanet olun
Dur bir şey daha söyleyeyim hemen
gitmeden Aslında ben çok konuşurum sıra
var
Aa Esra da gelmiş hoş gelmiş Çok kısa
bir şey söyleyeceğim çok duygusal bir
insanım burada Milyonlar bizi izliyor
izlesinler de
insana saygı kadına saygı çocuğa saygı
masum insanlara saygı hayvanlara saygısı
olan Milletler dünyada güçlü
milletlerdir diyorum ki şiddetin son
bulduğu sevginin dünyada kardeşliği
birliğin beraberliğin daim olduğu
yaşanılabilir bir dünya diliyorum